and Trump is at Camp David this morning
after days of referencing that he had
not left the White House in weeks mr.
Trump headed for the presidential
retreat touting a new treatment option
for those with severe cases of the
corona virus the Food and Drug
Administration approved an emergency
order for RIM des aveer Friday it's the
first drug to show faster recovery rates
in patients
Nikole Killion is at the White House
this morning Nicole good morning good
morning to you Michelle the president
and his task force call this drug
promising and a first step and will
prioritize it to those who are seriously
ill meantime the president says he will
use his time this weekend at Camp David
for calls and meetings all while social
distancing president Trump boarded
marine one for Camp David his first trip
outside of the White House since seeing
off the USNS comfort in late March
Friday in the Oval Office the president
announced the Food and Drug
Administration has granted emergency use
of REM de severe that's been the hot
thing also in the papers and in the
media for the last little while an
important treatment for hospitalized
coronavirus patients a recent clinical
trial showed the antiretroviral drug
could shorten recovery time in kovat 19
patients by an average of four days
manufacturer Gilead Sciences is donating
one-and-a-half million doses to the
federal government with initial
distribution to hospitals starting
Monday there are patients out there that
can benefit from this medicine today
that are hospitalized and we don't want
any time to waste for that the
announcement comes as the Trump
administration ramps up work for a
potential vaccine dubbed Operation warp
speed nothing has ever gone this fast
Kaleigh mackaninee made her debut in the
White House's first briefing by a press
secretary in more than a year I will
never lie to you you have my word on
that
the White House also faced new scrutiny
from a congressional panel seeking
testimony next week from Task Force
member dr. Anthony foul she a
spokesperson for the House
Appropriations Committee stated we have
been informed by an administration
official that the White House has
blocked doctor foul chief from
testifying the White House responded
while the Trump administration continues
its whole-of-government response - cove
at 19 it is counterproductive to have
the very individuals involved in those
efforts appearing at congressional
hearings CBS News has learned that foul
Chi will appear before a Senate panel
later this month
the Senate's actually back to work on
Monday and there's been some concern
about that after the Capitol physician
reportedly warned there weren't enough
tests for all of the senators but late
last night the Health Secretary tweeted
that testing machines and 1,000 rapid
test kits will now be made available
Dana
Nicole testing at the center of
everything thank you very much